[Music]
hey yeah welcome to the basement with
I'm Danish is o'neil yeah it's our
summer episode how was your summer been
not great yeah yeah I could tell
yeah still got a lawsuit going so can't
really talk about it alright well that's
unfortunate
oh well what do you say we dive right in
yeah I got something a little cheer you
up I think okay let's head to where is
this this is Italy we think no I think
the guys at time reduce America me this
is America baby
alright alright look look oral sex or
our sex demo you see oral sex I feel
even you oral sex use oral sex let us
firm on that man out do you think that
she left the sperm in her mouth from
that diamond all time he seems to think
that I don't know if we want someone
pointing at them yelling sex oral sex if
that's not bad enough than oral sex
demon yeah I'm gonna say it's not a good
day for this lady it's like I'd in the
back with the glasses looking over she's
like oh years ago okay let's see where
he goes why would you answer the door
the second time that David shows up the
demons that tricky first time he's it's
like hey I'm a demon you let a man
second time he's like hey pizza delivery
like oh I think I think he showed up the
second time and she's like you better
not put that penis in my mouth he's like
don't worry I'm not going to
and then he put it in the vagina it's a
bad precedent because you anyone could
be like I like I saw that guy you hooked
up with like well I have the church for
you I love the guy whose job is to hold
this woman while she goes through these
history on why did he hit her why not
and this demons crafty enough to work
his way into this lady's bed why why
would he answer this guy when you hit
the head it may be trying to force the
demon out of the ass okay it's like it's
not coming out of the mouths you've
tried that Mike is questioning whoo-hooo
you well everybody knows it's like a
undercover cop you have if they ask you
if you're a demon you got to say yes I'm
waiting for the rest of the crowd to do
[Laughter]
the two people behind it look like they
don't want their like I just thought
this was a regular Church yeah you mean
the lady wearing like the rainbow
sweater there's a lady wearing gloves
right there that she is what she's might
be having to pull the demon out of the
ass dude the demon scared he's been
exposed
yeah the demons running but this guy is
gonna make sure the demons gonna stay
and face this man's question also I
think the demon is like oh [ __ ] this
guy's calling out my game yes I know
women are gonna fall for this in this
church anymore let's see where it goes
from here speak speak out for you
who are you Oh No
there's a guy the batch are just eating
Donuts you do I can help you over for
the chair kicked over jack there's ever
been a PSA not to [ __ ] if you think that
this could possibly happened to you look
at the back wall it's all the people
whose heels from like walking it's all
their kids there's a wheelchair in the
back on the wall exec of the demon [ __ ]
away so hard she couldn't walk that
demon broke your legs who is this guy
all they do David exit like sexual demon
exercise also does bar mitzvahs ok yeah
he does weddings to first I thought
those were like saws in the back like
some medieval torture he's gonna saw the
demon out of you so I would get it out I
have to go in there with my own penis
and lure him out you kicked her in the
vagina it knocked her down yeah of
course everybody knows that that's the
demons Achilles heel the kick in the
vagina this woman's a hell of a
performer yeah where do you think that
he got her
that's an aerobics studio she's doing
foot fire she's moving around she could
have been like a Tina Turner's backup
dance it does look like Tina Turner all
right let's see this man interrogate and
berate this woman again see if he can
get rid of it to take the scarf off
because it wasn't effective yeah I've
done that on dates before have you ever
sprayed somebody down spray Febreze on
it yeah just other stuff yeah no I got
like I can't believe it's not butter
over the pants got it yeah it's lady in
the bags ready to clap she's like oh
yeah a great spray job
so you're that's holy water they take it
I would think yeah okay she's down
closet for a second that was like a guy
bowling the way he like went stupid pans
like a wood I love though that he had
like at his guy that he goes with all
the time he just threw the holy water
guy grabbed it out of the air he does he
look kind of like Obama from the side
you think it's what Obama's doing with
his free time
it's like Obama meets pitbull maybe
that's how he hails and like it says
Jesus is hard behind them but I don't
think maybe the Warlord's just cold we
don't know what that water was got a
keyboardist behind them or is that like
their sound man oh yeah big organ player
now they sit down and let's talk about
what we just did together how I punched
you in the head five times let's let's
go back to the video oh come on
somebody after I spray with the water
after I spray something came I white put
your hands together hallelujah after I
sprayed something came out white so he
goes all right now go to the bathroom
it's like I'm getting the [ __ ] out of
here I'm going down the toilet I'm gonna
infect somebody else I mean it sounds
like it sounds like he's talking about a
sexual experience after I sprayed it's
had it like sushi went to the bathroom
it was like oh that works you got it
yeah it'd be great if she came back it's
like what happened she's like I took it
to one of the best of my life he's like
a brown stuff come out he needs to spray
or isaac yeah here's a baby wipe I I
don't know I want to go to this church
I'll be perfectly on it just to be like
hey man I said I don't mind of a penis
Birds I think of a demon body got in
there when I was swimming I don't know
how does he know it's all out because
the demons tricky goodnight
to be out but really do you think he
just take some white stuff throws it out
he's like alright I'm gonna hide for a
while the demons eating yogurt like we
have right here that could be I'm
worried that the demons gonna come back
to her house knock on the door and she
can't resist clearly she's weak the
glory goes to Jesus yeah okay yeah
another woman's healed they put her
panties up on the wall you see in
previous episode I would sell those
panties demonic panty possession
probably go for like five hundred
dollars I'd say like ten grand
especially if you keep the white stuff
in the panties and then you have this
guy autograph Demon Slayer eye they
should make movies about this sort of
thing
yeah I'm for all we know there could be
like a religious series where this guy's
just go at it battling sex demons
afterwards I got to give you like a
really thorough exam to make sure that
this demons gone did you hear about it
there was a dude who I think he was a
priest and he was telling like man that
he could suck like demons that out of
them but I could I could see how that
could be true okay
that seems more believable this parking
guy I protect people with holy water at
least there is some sort of like action
happening yeah it's almost like he was
macing the vagina
like every time the pig reared its head
he was spreading in the face things
always like an episode of sexual cops
like something was coming out BB
spraying it back in what are these other
[ __ ] people thinking when they're
watching this they're just like when's
my turn you think oh think my head's not
gonna punch itself I was good
this vagina is not gonna kick itself I
like how he makes sounds that like the
punch isn't enough but you need to
punctuate it with I like the two mics I
like how there is somebody holding the
woman but there's also someone holding a
microphone to the woman roll a spare no
expense
yeah this is a high quality production
also there's a big like a Jumbotron
behind him but they're in a tiny room
the people that just want to drink
kool-aid and he doughnuts a watch I
would go would you I'd go watch this
live for sure I I would pay money to
watch this on a weekly basis yeah I
would ask could I be the guy who holds
the people while you're exercising the
sexual demon can I get a quick punch in
punch somebody said I want to do some
kicking around here you can do the noise
I'll do the headache starter ode we help
heal people yeah because this guy right
here this guy is not he's doing a
disservice because I have to be honest
with you folks demon possession sexual
demon possession is a real deal and
we've actually made a PSA about it that
we want to show you right now let's take
a look Oh having trouble urinating yeah
big time that's cuz you're paying for
two what oh yeah there's a demon in that
piece
oh you need to set him free Wow
you need to follow these simple steps my
friend okay
demonic general possession also known as
DGP is no laughing matter
we both had it I had it in high school
and I had it when I was six good news is
though it's very very painful it's also
highly treatable can't make sure you
know what to look out for
here are the warning sign symptom number
one people urination does it burn when
you pee that's because they're peeing
for two there's a demon in your wiener
get that demon out of your waders victim
to genital burning what your penis comes
into contact with a Bible sizzle sizzle
demon symptom three demon semen in your
undies doctors and pills won't cure this
big pharma doesn't even want you to know
that it exists they call badge '''l
possession things like UTIs an anal
possession IBS Crohn's or ulcerative
colitis big pharma more like Big Pharma
but they were all cured using our
one-of-a-kind demon extraction system
[Applause]
our patented rosary beads can remove any
demon from your sex organs and the good
news is when you're done they can be
used as jewelry toys for your kids anal
beads in the best chair of all as
prevention hero ways how to prevent DGP
dough try on swimsuit to the mall
without underwear never use your
genitals to open doors ATMs
both the baking machines and the
ass-to-mouth sex are a surer way to
catch it using a haunted dildo or a
secondhand dildo someone who just passed
away sleeping naked in a haunted hotel
don't have sex with demons and the
biggest thing of all spread awareness
talk about this with your kids your
co-workers and your religious leaders
and most importantly use condoms
they'll protect you from those pesky
STDs sexually transmitted demons penis
your O'Neill condoms do not prevent
sexually transmitted diseases or
pregnancy this ad is brought to you by
true org that's truth with an E so we
don't get sued
[Music]
how informative yeah man that was
amazing
yeah don't listen to that guy you listen
to the Danish you know Neil's we know
better we know how to rid those sexual
demons but so let's move on to this next
guys gonna this next guy is he's falling
in love let's see but let's see this
beautiful love story this TLC my name is
Nathaniel I'm 27 years old and I'm a
serious relationship with Michael oh
okay
whoa oh is that a Chevy lumina baby that
moved fast that's a man Nathaniel is in
a committed relationship with a car I
find this hard to believe there's people
who aren't in love with their car that
put the eyelashes on the headlights why
hasn't he done that yes he likes her
without the makeup or him I don't know
what is a man or a woman I would pay two
pair of jeans like over the trunk and
the rear wheels said he's in a committed
relationship so he's not seeing any
other cars at a moment realest luminous
men up there [ __ ] other cars it
started so normal with hi my name is
Nathaniel and then they went right into
and I have sex with my car in my
driveway how old do you think that guy
is he could be anywhere from 22 to like
44 think you said 28 there's 28 of them
so yeah how's the car well I may not be
enough but that's an older woman they
may not luminous in a wife may not be of
age let's see this guy the car in car
years let's see him kisses cars changed
he met chase in a resale lot about five
years ago
five it it was love at first sight its
body I've never want to see a car step
in the neutral so bad of my life I think
he would love it even thinking that he
was gonna kill me I want it to be you
Jace take me Jace you're doing this in
an draw an open driveway
imagine being his neighbors and you're
like dude he's kissing the car again
yeah sure like he's outside put the
privet kids in I can't have it watching
this look at him kiss that bumper then
all the Flies and all the stuff that
held that he keeps chase super clean no
he doesn't alright let's continue all
this
I think he's bothering in his interior
and everything just together just seemed
to fit not just felt an instant
connection
Nathaniel's obsession first developed as
a teenager when he would build model
cars but find true love until he met
chase I find this part of him the most
sexy just because the subtle lines and
curves
I'll give him a kiss here and just kind
of caress him down the side my initial
reaction whoa wait I thought that was
just hard to understand how cheap is her
rent they stay with this guy
you couldn't have you couldn't pay me to
live with this guy we're friends alone
you got to move it he's like no no the
rents really cheap it's great honestly I
don't know why I feel the way I do
but I just absolutely lived in his
neighborhood I would crash it we always
have such a good telling while he's
arriving he likes a lot of the same
music
they have a favorite song it's can't
fight this feeling by REO Speedwagon I
do getting just good possibly have a
favorite song with your wife and then
that's how to do something special for
him - how does he maintain that level of
pervert lust - at all times growth -
that it's stopped yeah that's like
standard issue that's guys got a problem
about that do you think he knows anyone
else who is like him who [ __ ] their car
your car club I gotta be honest with you
I don't think he knows anybody else
period it's his roommate and chick yeah
how did she agree to be on this video
yeah I don't know i doesn't blur my face
and do a voice alter yeah yeah if I
lived in his neighborhood I would just
go up behind the car and like tell
Victor I've spent all the time you like
look at my car as well I would egg his
car all the time and then they come kids
didn't get salmonella
let's see them drive listen to their
favorite song try to do something
special for him to the favorite date
would be going to the lookout area just
be with him mainly but no barriers
garrison ship with Chase goes beyond
dates and presents we have our times
when we get sexual
that's telling it that a class ring
there's guys got no class I think know
what we do the most often is I like to
lean over his fender and across his hood
and these little things like that and
just the sounds and kind of press up
against a magician and rub against him
like that until I come in my pants one
of his more bold positions is for me to
be underneath and you'll do it under the
car I think in this car could talk he
would say I [ __ ] hate you stop
kissing me you creep we we should save
that cat that was him head toddler that
lady pretend to be a toddler and save
this car from these creeps yeah so this
guy goes under deep so right now he's
just jerking it under there what is you
would think that your penis in the gas
or the muffler would be a position but
if you have a real tiny penis you could
probably get it in the oil you know that
oil drain plugs all that dipstick in
that car [ __ ] turd yeah okay
I've known some car [ __ ] in my day so
this guy just thrusts this is terrible
because it's out in the open like you
can't bring this car inside the garage
make it somewhere a little more private
everybody maybe his roommates like the
garage is mine Trudy
how great would be if you live this
neighborhood every time this guy was out
there'll be like to be a kid in this
neighborhood oh it's like a dream come
true his ride circles around his car on
your bike while he [ __ ] it yeah your
mom's like where you going go to the fan
Joe's house TV's [ __ ] that guard
doesn't stop like all right be home by
dinner how bad this guy's gonna weep
when this car can't run anymore here's
the thing Chevy lumina doesn't have a
tremendous reliability no he's gonna be
a beast to keep on the road you may want
a traverse yeah tell them you could fall
in love with a Honda or a Toyota
something a little more reliable does he
get jealous
he might isn't let anyone else have
people that don't understand it make fun
of you Nathaniel's so attached to chance
who rarely lets anyone else drive him
and never lets chase out on us from more
than 25 there have been Tom's brought
tears to my eyes because I wasn't with
him at work yeah why would you it really
bothers me when he gets dinged or
scratched if somewhere we have him chase
I my heart would just song wait this
guy's a job wait pause it right here
quit there like hey what's he doing oh
into the bad luck all right let's uh
let's keep going with this and see where
this adds oh well when he gets dinged or
scratched if somewhere ever have him
chase I my heart would just stop
and just have to gather myself here I'm
sorry I'm concerned from that they know
emotion was I think life would be easier
if he did change I mean sounds like she
wants Nathaniel's roommate Kim is one of
the few people who know the full extent
of his love life I guess the reason all
the other people to watch this
documentary yeah I don't know the
response I'm gonna get I always worry
about that we pause it for a second
discussed it so this guy doesn't know
what response
he's gonna get to this I think it's
pretty like I don't think there's
anybody that's like oh yeah thumbs up
bro good job other than himself even his
own roommates like dude yeah does very
like low-key about it she's like I think
he maybe could do it so she's like I
used to live with the bridge [ __ ] this
is actually a step up at least he can
give me a ride somewhere what the hood
though wouldn't that be like that's more
sexual I would think yeah it's like
looking at the insides but Nathaniel's
biggest fear is how his relationship
could affect his career as a customer
service technician everybody found out
I'd be worried that if I were to go on a
TV show but I love him to death I
wouldn't trade him for the world right
baby
kissing sounded disgusting a little bit
I've never seen a kissing and like the
rubbing was also creepy the rubbing was
more like way more sexual than just
rubbing alright what he's worried about
people who the customer service industry
finding out about this way just don't
tell him on the [ __ ] phone when they
call we hashed it thick by the way oh
yeah what am i doing later I'll be
having sex with a car I'll let you know
you have a prom with your blender
I tell you about chases car that a
[ __ ] it's crazy the good do you like
do you think he worries about chase
breaking up with him he just goes out
and the car's gone
the no dude I would steal this car for
sure I'm gonna bring it back all beat up
I'll bring it back with my jizz all over
the hood under the hood I would write
[ __ ] you and come over
remember in Cape Fear when De Niro puts
himself under the car with the belt it's
get to it that's what I would do I'd be
under there be like get out of here and
the fan nobody slides under you're up
what's going on you're like I'm [ __ ]
right now I'm not seeing my sock on the
room the mirror I'm under here that
would be great to just hide under his
car all day til he comes to [ __ ] it he
loves me they're like how did this you
know deal die well they're hiding under
this car then it drove off and killed
them
Wow this is a remake of Knight Rider in
the making this is actually this is
behind-the-scenes footage of Michael
Knight and yeah KITT this is how their
relationship really went down all right
all right where do you go from that yeah
let's move on here to go to inventions
shall we I think we have a picture of
this yeah don't be fooled it's not a
video how's that milk oh it's spicy
here we go so this young lady is a true
innovator yeah this is an England yeah
she's made two different types of chairs
one is for a man and what is for a woman
the one on her left is for the man to
prevent him from manspreading yeah this
is he's like I want to show my dick but
I can't here's my problem so she said
that she had an issue with guys always
spreading their legs on the subway and
crowding her space the thing is she
doesn't have balls these things need air
can't cut circulation off what if it's a
long train ride and by the way it is
such a problem that it something needs
to be invented to stop it
I don't ride do a lot of public transit
but I'm gonna say no no it is not at all
and so so now this guy by the way look
at the woman flaunting it she's like I
could spread as wide as I want it's like
in your face yeah this is how we're
gonna get along this sort of baby why
can't we all air out our genitals
equally yeah like everybody can spread
their life he is a demon in there and
he's trying to let it out by spreading
his legs it's true by keeping the demon
in you could do severe damage look how
proud she has of herself right there I
just cured cancer just like restrictive
I read this there was an article and it
said like how long this took to do and I
feel working on it yeah well maybe if
you made the ass part not so wide you'd
have just enough room for everybody it
looks like a chair for like the smallest
fattest person it's like all funneling
it into something lady you don't have
balls you don't know what's going on
here these things aren't great to walk
around with we need to end manspreading
now more inventions Franklin they said
was trying to stop it when he got struck
by lightning with his kite manspreading
yeah it was God saying oh really and
then have to spread their legs these
people that are posing they was like
they
being against their will that guy looks
so uncomfortable right now he's like oh
I hope this doesn't this photo shoot
doesn't take too long he's sitting in a
torture device
crushing my dick right like knots like
there's a difference between like way
like you don't have to sit like this
where you're like no I don't think your
knees together also with this device
you're gonna get a lot more guys
reaching their hands into their pants to
adjust themselves so that they can close
their legs all the way I don't know
about you but my balls they sag down
minor above my belt line Oh see you're
fine oh actually hang my now at the top
of my cheek so I don't crowd anybody I
don't know if it offends people doing it
I don't know if people go those are your
nut sack hanging out on top I'm like
yeah I want to give you more room if I
was subjected to this I would go legs
out like this at all times like you want
like this walk over my legs oh you have
to have some good core strength to hold
that the whole time yeah especially on a
seat like this I was rocking and rolling
you know what I usually don't sit when I
ride the subway I stand but I stand like
this they put my legs up where I
actually lay down with my legs up above
my head she saves a lot of space I was
on a subway in New York I was with my
beautiful girlfriend Courtney and my
baby baby Barb yeah and when Courtney
would have the baby like this it would
part like the Red Sea to let her sit
down like 50 people I'm wearing the baby
every woman on that subway not one move
even young women everybody's thing just
looking at me and it's like that's
harder than being pregnant because the
baby's older heavier I could hit her
head on a pole in their defense you were
breastfeeding or using that device that
we talked about last episode yeah and
that makes it harder to do
where are the inventions for that that's
true father carrying a baby so I I don't
agree with this or if you want to do
this you should cut a hole in the bottom
and put a fan that blows up to kind of
cool the product you were to say that
you could drape your dick and balls down
through the hole even better idea we
need to invent yes also you know she's
taking up all no she's airing out her
vagina
it's not it's about revenge and this
shouldn't be about room no let's all
just sit like a
I agree 100% it's not two inventions
despite people can we all just get along
all the men there like look as sad as
you can look you've done bad yeah I
think she is a bright future I don't
think just sell straps that you can tie
your legs up like hog-tie men when they
go sit on the subway or leg shackles
yeah like trying to spread nose yeah try
spreading your cheeks now why don't they
let us wear miniskirts then we can't
spread our legs at all I would actually
be down for that
I think we're allowed to wear many
school well I know but like where people
aren't other guys aren't really that
idiot with miniskirt on but we all wear
them you need to invent something yeah
or like a tube dress like one of those
tube dresses for me I would wear that in
Mexico because there is there's such a
problem with sexual harassment on the
train that they put men that look like
they made their living they made the
chairs have a penis oh yeah it's
attached and so they want men to sit on
the penis and feel the discomfort yeah
and to remind you that you have a penis
and that you should watch out for it I
guess because I guess they all have a
demonic possession which seems like it's
not gonna solve anything it's just gonna
be like alright I'll stand up I would
just be yeah I'd be like there's nowhere
left to sit except all the penis chairs
I still have to sit on one of those
people are sucking I'm already so I'm
just gonna stand over here if you spread
it it makes it look like it's your penis
man spread they need to get this
invention talk to this lady is gonna be
in the future Bill Gates honestly though
I've never had a problem with like man
even if you sing next to another man him
spreading your legs and you were
spreading occasionally you like wrap it
over here he's like here open up a
little bit you're too time call that
spreading you know we should we should
invent a device that actually cranks
your legs open as far as they'll go you
shove him in there they call those the
Van Damme so yeah you should do the
split on a train across all the city
okay that was definitely a good this
yeah try to contain him lady yeah I want
to start men spread trains only that's
true we see every seats like eight feet
apart
these fits five guys ready to move on
let's do it okay let's go to a picture
of a young man I think he got arrested
this is mugshot
this dude's 19 years old yeah he
literally got arrested for looking like
who do you Benjamin buttons that like
it's illegal to look 40 when you're 19
wherever this guy got taken in dude good
luck going to prom with this look
they're like sir
[Laughter]
if you go through another school's prom
they're not allowing a man I saw a
picture when this guy was 13 and he
looked actually older than this I saw
his Little League guy they took pictures
little card and he was balding at 10
years old he could buy beer God has
cursed them with no hair here but a
vicious unibrow yes if you could just
have that unibrow transplanted above his
lip you'd have a full month's pass
speaking of creep stash as he is rocking
the creeps - hard unfortunately just by
looks alone this guy has no other chance
at life than to be a pedophile maybe
like an older man model I feel terrible
I do and on top of it now he's in jail
yeah but they'll be like oh he's a no
jeez he's 60 years old when he gets the
prison yeah like how many times you've
been in here you think I'm 1994 44 years
that's crazy you should just shave it on
the side the head or the eyebrows
everything
just shave the eyebrows and everything
if my daughter brought this guy home
that's her boyfriend at 19 what if
they're what if his parents were both
like models yeah it is Christie Brinkley
and the other model guy the other model
guy that you know yeah this is Fabio's
this is Tyson Beckford and I think this
guy's American but he looks like he's
from like I don't know somewhere not it
looks like he's it could be like Borat's
like nephew he's like a Kazakhstan
refugee it is quite tall I can't get
over
now it's beautiful it's wild times it is
beautiful I do feel bad for him but I
also don't know what he went to jail for
you could be a total piece of crap no I
think it was just a drug charge just
makes me even sadder
yeah if you're the cops feel like I get
why you're doing drugs let this guy go
it's like when did you start when you
were three cuz it's poor guy
so everybody out there leave this guy
alone and if your list if you're
watching sir we'd love to have you in
the live studio audience
absolutely because we've treated you so
well I would like to call him on the
phone and talk to him in prison would it
be like a really high-pitched voice
what'd you expect that would be the
ultimate curse well good luck to you in
the future sir good news is the older
all uphill from here all right well you
got a special treat to wrap the show up
yeah as you guys all know we like to
introduce new comedians to the world and
all we can get though not all we can get
but every week everyone just says we
want more fing child anyway we don't
anything new we want the old yeah but
there have been a lot of complaints
because as you also know cuz you watch
the show all the time we instead of
having the comedians perform for the
audience
we as the host always feel like we're
getting gypped so we have the comedian
performed for us but there's been a lot
of backlash from that so what we've done
we actually are going to spin him around
so that everybody can enjoy his comedy
stylings so ladies and gentlemen here he
is thank you
[Applause]
hold on one second let me get some slack
and at my here we go
Ryan Yoho Jeff Dennis Ryan sugar powder
Jeffrey you got Java thank you
humming don't wear your new mono times
your way up with your dollar take a
shirt
[Laughter]
Jeffrey cassava follow new poetry gosh
y'all don't want the other Ryan titanium
a or cheat our laboratory Ryan the Baba
oh mama yeah daughter pound parabens
Java
Tomica dice yeah why I put lashes on the
shop function you go hard and you gotta
pay your water do I am coach I fourth
Amla total losing man why you booted out
I'm not sure from a diner hydraboost
yeah ha ha ha shake your the
hypothalamus yeah I approached a
photographer what mahadesh yeah ha ha ha
so much wrong no no I got mine negative
Ryan what aperture how them all right
keep going Ryan go chat with him now I
don't border harder thunder war without
night job
[Music]